hat der verkehrsminister gelogen oder
nicht die mautbetreiber sagen vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss aus und belasten
andreas scheuer noch mehr coroner
risikogebiete und neue regeln einfach
mal in den urlaub fliegen wird wieder
schwieriger und wut und entsetzen in
indien nach einer tödlichen gruppen
vergewaltigung gehen tausende auf die
straße
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den 19 uhr nachrichten für den sport ist
katja stresow an meiner seite hallo und
guten amt eigentlich wollte
verkehrsminister scheuer am heutigen
ersten oktober feiern den start der
pkw-maut daraus wurde bekanntlich nichts
der europäische gerichtshof hatte das
csu prestige projekt gestoppt das
problem die verträge mit den
netzbetreibern waren schon abgeschlossen
sie fordern schadensersatz und scheuer
muss in den nächsten stunden die fragen
des untersuchungsausschusses beantworten
die erste lautet warum unterschrieb er
milliardenschwere verträge bevor der
europäische gerichtshof über die maut
sein urteil fällte die zweite frage hat
heuer den bundestag in dieser sache
belogen
für den minister geht es jetzt um alles
für den deutschen steuerzahler um 560
millionen euro
aus berlin berichtet mathis feldhoff es
wird hitzig im out
untersuchungsausschuss und immer mehr
zum fernduell zwischen der ehemaligen
betreiber firma und minister scheuer
klaus peter schulenberg gesellschafter
der maut firma auto ticket bestätigt
heute dass er persönlich dem minister
angeboten habe den vertragsabschluss zu
verschieben nach dem urteil des ogh über
unser treffen berichtet wir haben
geliefert wir haben
software entwickeln in infrastruktur
investiert und wir sind für dieses
debakel wir nicht verantworten
der frust sitzt tief bei der maut firma
und die aussagen belasten minister
schwer
vor einem jahr hatte der noch behauptet
dass ein angebot zur verschiebung nie
vorgelegen habe zwar nicht thema in dem
gespräch am 22 november
für die opposition ist nach den ersten
beiden zeugen die sachlage klar man kann
jetzt nach dem zweiten zeugen sehr gut
sehen dass der zweite zeuge komplett den
minister und auch die csu versenkt hat
für mich ist es klar dass der minister
am 25 september 2009 10 nicht die
wahrheit im parlament gesagt hat schon
der geschäftsführer der firma auto
ticket schneble hatte am vormittag
ausgesagt dass euer sich intensiv in die
verhandlungen eingebracht und am ende
sogar in einer so wörtlich
kurzschlussreaktion gekündigt habe die
unionsvertreter bleiben heute bei ihrer
linie
die zeugen zu diskreditieren und so ihre
glaubwürdigkeit in zweifel zu ziehen
können sie ausschließen dass schulenberg
die wahrheit gesagt hat wir können
derzeit beides nicht und dann gilt immer
der grundsatz es muss beschissen wäre es
wird mit einer langen nacht gerechnet
wann der verkehrsminister kommt scheint
derzeit offen die koalition hat gestern
überraschend noch einen
entlastungszeugen geladen
gunther love energy sie beobachten für
uns den untersuchungsausschuss in berlin
drei zeugen haben ausgesagt wie sieht's
aus wird es eng für den verkehrsminister
also wenn man hier so zuhört dann fragt
man sich wie er unbeschadet aus der
ganzen sache raus gehen soll auch zeugen
nummer 3 georg habs der österreicher hat
jetzt
gerade eben gesagt dass es ein angebot
gegeben habe das ganze noch einmal zu
verschieben hat also dem
verkehrsminister auch widersprochen es
wird jetzt sehr spannend werden wie der
dritte der herr nächste zeuge aussagen
wird da geht es um den ehemaligen
staatssekretär gerhard schulz der bei
den gesprächen anwesend gewesen ist was
sagt er wie hat er diese gespräche
wahrgenommen also am ende könnte es zu
einer art pattsituation kommen wenn die
drei betreiber behaupten der
verkehrsminister liegt unter
verkehrsminister uns ein staatssekretär
sagen sie erinnert sich an die ganze
sache ganz anders
dann wird es hier fraglich wie wie die
ganze sache ausgeht die spd hat schon
vorgebaut hat immer gesagt es muss ein
eine nachgewiesene lüge sein und das ist
eben die frage ob ein mehr an hand
dieser aussagen sich das ganze
nachweisen lässt die befragungen
hingehen jetzt übrigens relativ zügig
voran
alle halten sich hier bei der befragung
an die vorgegebenen zeitrahmen damit
steigen die chancen dass andreas scheuer
heute tatsächlich noch vernommen wird da
gab es heute mal zwischendurch zeitliche
fragen als der erste zeuge über vier
stunden befragt werden worden ist also
wir sind gespannt was heute noch kommt
soviel bisher vom bundes
untersuchungsausschuss gegen andreas
scheuer
vielen dank und heller kremlkritiker
navalny gibt dem russischen präsidenten
die schuld am giftanschlag auf sich ich
behaupte dass hinter der tat putin steht
sagte er in einem spiegel interview der
wichtigste anhaltspunkt dafür sei der
einsatz des tödlichen nervengifts mohawk
das können nur vom russischen
geheimdienst kommen den deutschen sei er
sehr dankbar sagte er noch deutschland
sei ein besonderes land für ihn geworden
um den fall einer wahl geht es heute
auch in brüssel wo sich die staats und
regierungschefs der eu treffen und
wieder einmal bei den aktuellen
problemen themen nach einer gemeinsamen
linie suchen
die liste ist lang es geht unter anderem
um den heftigen gas streit mit der
türkei im mittelmeer
auch der blutige konflikt in
bergkarabach ist thema und die frage wie
die eu reagieren soll auf die
mutmassliche wahlfälschung und gewalt in
belarus gewaltige probleme also anne
gellinek in brüssel ist man bei den
sanktionen für belarus schon vorangeht
wird die eu jetzt handeln es geht heute
abend um die weltpolitik fähigkeit der
europäischen union und der wäre ist
natürlich ein gutes signal wenn die
europäische union die lange ins auge
gefassten sanktionen gegen belarus
tatsächlich beschließen würde
dem steht bislang das prinzip der
einstimmigkeit entgegen zypern will
seine zustimmung zur sanktionen in
belarus nicht geben solange es nicht
gleichzeitig strafmaßnahmen gegen die
türkei gibt wegen deren gas bohrungen im
mittelmeer die staats und
regierungschefs sitzen jetzt genau über
dieses thema zusammen am nachmittag sah
es so aus als ob die blockade zyperns
möglicherweise gelöst werden könnte aber
offen aber sicher ist das nicht die
frage ist offen
und dann ist da auch noch ein thema
frisch dazu gekommen nämlich dass der
gefährdeten rechtsstaatlichkeit von
ländern wie polen und ungarn
ja das thema steht eigentlich gar nicht
auf der tagesordnung des gipfels sorgt
aber für erheblichen streit die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft hat einen vorschlag
gemacht nachdem man ländern die die
rechtsstaatlichkeit aushöhlen eu-mitteln
kürzen kann
dieser vorschlag geht den ländern die es
betrifft nämlich polen und ungarn viel
zu weit anderen ländern in westeuropa
niederlande und skandinavien geht er
nicht weit genug die bundeskanzlerin als
vertreterin der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft muss nun versuchen
am rande des gipfels die wogen zu
glätten
denn wenn es keine einigung über den
rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus gibt
dann kann das gesamte corona hilfspaket
der eu nicht in kraft treten
vielen dank anna klinik in brüssel
überraschende wende im prozess um den
mord am kasseler regierungspräsident
präsidenten lübke der wegen beihilfe
mitangeklagte markus h kommt aus der
untersuchungshaft frei gegen ihn gebe es
keinen hinreichenden dringenden
tatverdacht mehr so die begründung des
oberlandesgerichts frankfurt
der ebenfalls angeklagte stefan er hat
zugegeben lücke vor seinem haus
erschossen zu haben
aber auch markus h als mittäter schwer
belastet die schwedische modekette h&m
hat hunderte mitarbeiter überwacht und
ausgespäht
vor einem jahr wurde der fall bekannt
den datenschützer
beispiellos nennen das jetzt verhängte
rekord bussgeld bestätigt dass rund 35
millionen euro soll h&m bezahlen
jahrelang seien angestellte der filiale
in nürnberg überwacht worden so der
zuständige datenschutzbeauftragte
so sammelte der konzern information
unter anderem darüber ob jemand
krankheitssymptome oder etwa familiäre
probleme hatte die herbstferien stehen
vor der tür
eigentlich eine beliebte reisezeit um
noch einmal im ausland sonne zu tanken
diesmal dürften wegen corona deutlich
weniger menschen urlaub gebucht haben
von drei viertel weniger umsatz spricht
der deutsche reiseverband und die die
noch fahren müssen den neuen
reisewarnungen der regierung im blick
behalten da hat sich zwar einiges
geändert und doch gilt fast überall gibt
es risikogebiete thomas garcia palmen
statt herbstlaub ab ins warme das wäre
schön aber wohin bei immer neuen regeln
kann man überhaupt reisen wir hatten es
vor aber wir haben jetzt einfach durch
corona jetzt doch gekämpft ich würde nur
eben wo man reisen hin darauf verbote
gibt es nicht warnungen schon die welt
wegen corona neu bewertet vorbei ist
eine pauschale reisewarnung jetzt wird
auch außerhalb europas jedes land
einzeln geprüft
aktuell gilt in 138 ländern eine
reisewarnung dort gibt es im
wochenschnitt mehr als 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100.000 einwohnern
auch in europa gibt es neue
risikogebiete ganz belgien etwa und fast
ganz frankreich urlaub im risikogebiet
hat auch neue folgen rückreise formen 15
oktober heißt man muss sich testen
lassen und bis zum negativergebnis in
quarantäne neu wohl ab dem 15 oktober
gilt immer erst mindestens fünf tage zu
hause in quarantäne
dann erst der test ein experten-tipp in
diesem corona zeiten empfehle ich ganz
klar die pauschalreise der
pauschaltourist es besser geschützt wenn
es nach der buchung zum problem in
seinem reiseziel kommt wird das land
also zum risikogebiet
hat dann kann der pauschaltourist
kostenfrei vom vertrag zurücktreten
genau das im einzelfall auch möglich bei
einer neuen warnstufe orange eine art
reisewarnung leid heißt vor reisen wird
abgeraten weil sie schwierig werden
beispiel thailand dort gibt es kaum
infektionen aber wegen corona dürfen
touristen nicht ins land länder ohne
jegliche warnung viele bleiben nicht
innerhalb europas
immerhin auch die beliebten ziele
italien griechenland zypern und malta
dort kann man ohne einschränkungen
urlaub machen stand jetzt das kann sich
aber jederzeit ändern
was ist derzeit risikogebiet was nicht
auch in der zdf- heute- app informieren
wir sie ausführlich und immer aktuell
auch bei uns steigen die zahlen weiter
das robert koch institut meldet mehr als
2500 coroner neue infektionen innerhalb
von 24 stunden das sind rund 700 mehr
als gestern auch der durchschnitt der
letzten sieben tage ist deutlich
gestiegen
demnach haben sich täglich 1980 menschen
neu angesteckt gestern lag der schnitt
noch bei 1870 mitten in der korona
pandemie kommt jetzt auch noch die
grippesaison wobei man sich gegen
influenza immerhin impfen lassen kann
wozu bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
auch dringend rät konkret empfehlen
ärzte die impfung ab oktober
dafür stehen laut
bundesgesundheitsministerium insgesamt
26 millionen impfdosen bereit deutlich
mehr als in den vergangenen wintern in
denen sich jeweils nur etwa 15 millionen
menschen immunisieren ließen trotzdem
drohen diesmal regionale engpässe oliver
deuker ein kleiner pieks mit großer
wirkung die grippe saison steht vor der
tür
dazu wieder steigende corona zahlen
allgemeinmediziner dr bernd in hannover
rät zur vorsicht
ich empfehle auf jeden fall jetzt die
impfung durchführen zu lassen gegen
grippe weil die kombination aus einer
cupid erkrankung und einer grippe kann
lebensgefährlich sein
gerade chronisch kranke
menschen die mit vielen anderen personen
zu tun haben aus dem öffentlichen
bereich schwangere und medizinisches
personal sollte sie impfen lassen
26 millionen impfdosen hat deutschland
für diese grippe saison geschafft bei
über 80 millionen einwohnern
fehlt da nicht was ja klingt aber
zunächst nur so wie wir sagen müssen
dass wir in den vergangenen jahren immer
so zu 13 bis 15 millionen impf dosen
verimpft haben jährlich und das wir ja
auch nicht alle 81 millionen
bundesbürger impfen müssen sondern im
wesentlichen risikogruppe und die für
die city ziert ist erst die
risikogruppen damit der impfstoff für
sie reicht dann die anderen so die
maßgabe der involvierten verbände ärzte
und krankenkassen aber schon jetzt
zeichnet sich ab dass ich wegen der
korona pandemie mehr menschen gegen
grippe impfen lassen wollen als in den
jahren zuvor
es könnte zu regionalen engpässen und
wartezeiten kommen
ich habe mich noch nie impfen lassen
gegen grippe aber jetzt unter diesen
umständen halte es für sinnvoll um eine
doppel ansteckung zu vermeiden sollte
ich mich mit 19 anstecken dass ich da
nicht unruhig und krippe darauf bekomme
die hoffnung der mediziner die krone
schutzmaßnahmen wie masken und abstand
könnten helfen die zahl der
grippeerkrankungen niedrig zu halten
gastwirte mussten ja wegen corona ihre
betriebe wochen lang schließen besonders
für sie ist die heutige entscheidung des
münchner landgerichts interessant es
sprach eine münchner wird gut eine
million euro zu weil schließungen nach
infektionsschutzgesetz von der
versicherung abgedeckt sein
die unterlegene versicherungskammer
argumentiert kobelt 19 sei im vertrag
nicht ausdrücklich genannt und kündigte
berufung an
sie haben sich alle um den zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft verdient gemacht
sagt bundespräsident steinmeier über die
menschen die er heute mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet hat
darunter der virologe christian drosten
geehrt für seine weltweit anerkannten
erkenntnisse zum corona
infektionsgeschehen landrat stephan
pusch bekam die auszeichnung für seinen
corona krisen-management im kreis
heinsberg und ex fußballprofi thomas
hitzlsperger wurde geehrt weil er sich
für toleranz und gegen homophobie 1
ein ganz anderes thema jetzt alle 15
minuten und das ist eine offizielle zahl
der regierung wird in indien eine frau
vergewaltigt ein besonders grausamer
fall löst gerade landesweit nicht nur
entsetzen und empörung aus die menschen
gehen auch auf die straße damit sich
endlich etwas ändert allein mit härteren
strafen sagen sie sei es nicht getan
normen odenthal es ist eine nacht und
nebelaktion die indische polizei
verbrennt die leiche einer 19-jährigen
um noch mehr unruhe zu vermeiden heißt
es um noch mehr spuren zu verwischen
sagen andere
die junge frau starb ihr rückgrat
gebrochen misshandelt vergewaltigt von
vier männern allesamt aus einer höheren
gesellschaftlichen kaste das opfer
gehörte zu niedrigsten
auch das sorgt für so viel unmut vor dem
krankenhaus wo die frau zuletzt ums
überleben kämpfte liegen die nerven bei
vielen bleibt der vater des opfers
fordert gerechtigkeit für ihn heißt dass
die täter müssten gehängt werden das sei
doch die einzig denkbare strafe vor
kurzem erst kamen diese vier männer an
den galgen die peiniger von nirvana ihr
fall hatte die welt schockiert eine
gruppen vergewaltigung in einem bus
mitten in delhi 2012 war das nach langem
juristischen hin und her sollte die
hinrichtung auch abschreckung seien die
leute fordern immer harte strafen aber
sie fragen nicht wie es so weit kommen
konnte dass wir nicht die tief
verwurzelte ungerechtigkeit die
diskriminierung der frau überwinden kann
man sich die schlimmsten strafen
ausdenken das bringt nichts
er bestimmt sie gehorcht dieses
erniedrigen de rollenbild ist
weitverbreitet übergriffe erreichen
rekordzahlen alle 15 minuten eine
vergewaltigung und die dunkelziffer wird
viel höher sein
indien gilt als das für frauen
gefährlichste land der welt es muss sich
was ändern vieles sogar zwei jahre lang
saß sie deutsch kurdische sängerin hosen
djane in einem türkischen gefängnis
jetzt ist sie überraschend freigekommen
eigentlich hatte ein türkisches gericht
sie zu mehr als sechs jahren haft
verurteilt
der vorwurf mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation
dann aber hatte ihre anwältin einspruch
gegen die unverhältnismäßig lange
haftzeit erhoben und dem wurde jetzt
stattgegeben
turbulent ging es heute am dann ruhiger
forst zu polizei und umweltaktivisten
standen sich gegenüber
weil die rodungsarbeiten für den ausbau
der a 49 zwischen gießen und kassel
begann die aktivistinnen besetzten
zahlreiche bäume und versuchten so die
bagger zu stoppen
anwohner der umliegenden dörfer
versprechen sich weniger lernen durch
das neue autobahnstück tja und jetzt der
sport mit katja und einer großen ehre
heute für trainer und top stürmer von
bayern münchen und dies absolut verdient
hansi flick wurde heute in die ohren der
schweiz zu europas trainer des jahres
gekürt und der beste spieler heißt in
diesem jahr weder cristiano ronaldo noch
lionel messi sondern er kommt ebenfalls
aus münchen und es ist robert
lewandowski was ihnen an trophäen in den
weg kommt träumen die bayern in diesem
jahr ungeniert ab allen voran robert
lewandowski triple-gewinn in bundesliga
champions league und pokal auch
torschützenkönig
deutschlands fußballer des jahres und
nun auch europas bester kicker vor
manuel neuer und kevin de bruyne europas
trainer des jahres natürlich der mann
von der bayern bank hansi flick dankbar
und bescheiden ohne mein team drumherum
meint mein coaching staff ist es nie
gesagt weil sie mich halt akte ich immer
unterstützen so unglaublich wie das
ganze fußball jahr 2020 die erfolge der
bayern und ihres stürmers robert
lewandowski und es wurde nicht nur
geehrten jung sondern auch ausgelost die
champions league gruppen nämlich und die
bayern treffen in gruppe a unter anderem
auf atletico madrid
schwieriger wird es für gladbach in
gruppe b gegen real madrid und inter
mailand der bvb er mit losglück in
gruppe f leipzig dagegen in der hammer
gruppe h gegen paris und manchester
united bayern und dortmund also zunächst
mit machbaren aufgaben im kampf um die
europäische krone das deutsche krönchen
hat sich gestern abend der rekordmeister
aufgesetzt bayern münchen gewann im
supercup gegen den bvb mit
32 josua kimmig mit dem entscheidenden
treffer und einer mischung aus willen
glück und können der fünfte titel für
die bayern in dieser saison und in paris
bei den french open haben drei deutsche
tennisprofis die dritte runde erreicht
laura siegemund gewann das duell gegen
teamkollegin julia goerges qualifikant
daniel meier besiegte überraschend jan
lennard struff und bereits gestern abend
zitterte sich alexanders wäre in einem
fünf-satz-krimi gegen den franzosen
hervé eine runde weiter nach vier
stunden verwandelte er seinen ersten
matchball und kann morgen dann ins
achtelfinale einziehen
danke katja der oktober ist ja ein
richtiger herbstmonat ob sich das wetter
danach richtet das sagt ihnen gleich
gunther tiersch das war es von uns danke
ihnen für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie und drei
viertel 10 zum heute-journal und wir
sind morgen wieder für sie da punkt 19
uhr
jetzt wünschen wir ihnen noch einen
angenehmen abend